In the real world, problems tend not to solve just one specific puzzle,
but they exist in an environment.
They occupy a niche in an environment that evolves over time,
and we can plot the program's evolution
through a multidimensional space,
and we can think of the different axes along this space,
and one of the most important axes is correctness.
Does the program do the right thing?
Another axis is efficiency.
Does it do it fast enough?
Another axis is features.
What exactly does it do?
And another one is elegance,
and I'm using the word elegance here coming from Richard O'Keefe,
a programmer who said "Elegance is not optional."
And elegance encompasses a number of attributes,
or as they're sometimes called, "ity."
That is, things that end in i-t-y like clarity,
simplicity, and generality are all part of elegance.
We can think of our program as occupying a point
in this multidimensional space, and we'd really like it to be
over here on the right where the correctness is high,
although correctness doesn't have to be 100%.
We all use programs that crash occasionally, and the programs are still useful to us.
And then over time, the program evolves and moves in some of these directions.
If the program is too slow, then we have to move it up
along the efficiency direction,
so we have to re-architect it and move it up to make it faster.
Over time, we want to add more features to our program,
so say for a poker program we want to deal with
wild cards, or we want to deal with having to deal with ties,
and so we move out along the feature dimension
and move that program to a new space.
And then sometimes we think about moving the program to a new point
in the space of elegance, so moving along the elegance dimension
without increasing the correctness or features or efficiency.
And in some sense you might think "Well, that's not really doing anything."
"Changing the elegance isn't gaining you any of these features."
But what it is gaining you is nothing right now,
but it's gaining you something for the future.
A program that is more elegant is easier to maintain,
easier to change, and so what you're doing
is you're buying time in the future by making the program
easier to maintain today.
Now, when I think of a point in this multidimensional space,
here we have correctness, and we're up against the right edge
but maybe not quite all the way to the right edge,
and similarly with all these other features.
Now, Voltaire was not a programmer,
but he gave some very good advice to programmers and engineers.
He said, "The best is the enemy of the good,"
and so what Voltaire meant by this is if you're striving for perfection,
then you may waste too much time.
You may make a bad engineering tradeoff to say
"I'm going to have to get to 100% correctness,
and I'm going to spend so much time doing that when I could have been doing something else."
"I could have been adding more features or adding other attributes to the program."
So you have to learn to be a good engineer and make good tradeoffs.
For any change you make in this multidimensional space,
any improvement you make in any of the dimensions,
there's a benefit to that.
You make the program more correct or more featureful or more efficient.
But there's also a cost. It takes you time to do that.
And you have to learn to make the right tradeoffs and say
"What do I need most?"
"Which direction do I need to move, or am I done?"
"Do I not have to move anymore?"